thanks very much for that
introduction and thanks for having me
today
so the title of my talk is wireless
power transfer
and rf energy harvesting new options for
system designers
so i am going to be talking about
ambient rf
as indicated and i'll also be talking
about some other rf power transfer
schemes
let's see now the reason i call it new
options for system designers is
not because i'm going to be talking very
much about design but
one of the things i think is most
important and interesting about wireless
power is the the different design
options that it will create so before i
get started i'd just
like to acknowledge my graduate students
and an alumni
this is a lancet sample who is my first
phd student
uh he graduated about a month after i
started at
uw because i've been work we've been
working together at intel for about five
years before that
so i thought if i could only crank out
one phd student a month i'd really be
have something going so far it's slowed
down unfortunately
now before i get into the meat of the
talk i'll just give you a little
overview of my group
i call the group sensor systems and
from the name you might think that
that's all about inventing new sensors
and we do do some of that which is what
i have labeled down here at the bottom
but we're also interested in all the
other things around that
that it takes uh you know that you need
to take an isolated sensor and turn it
into a usable system
so that involves communicating with with
uh sensors
and what most of what i'm going to be
talking about today is actually about
powering
uh sensor and actuator systems um
we're also interested in various
applications of sensor systems so
things like ubiquitous computing uh
medical applications
robotics and i'll actually talk about
some of some of each of those
but the bulk of the talk today is going
to be about
our work in wireless power whoops the b
key and i will unpack these acronyms as
we go these are several different
systems
that we've developed so before
i talk about some of the specific
systems why wireless power i mean in
some ways it seems so obvious that you
don't even need to motivate it but it's
kind of interesting to think about
what are the specific benefits partially
because different applications are kind
of benefiting from different things
so one of them is is cord elimination so
here's a mess of cords that you see
obviously wireless data can help
eliminate quite a few cords
but it doesn't may not eliminate all of
them of course one way to eliminate the
power cord at least some of the time is
to use batteries
so battery elimination is another
potential benefit of wireless power
that works in some applications and if
you think about
what are the benefits of getting rid of
batteries more specifically
uh one is your device can potentially be
you know have a perpetual lifetime if
it's getting the rf kind of live
then you may be able to eliminate the
battery altogether and not worry
about it dying
if you can eliminate the battery you can
reduce the size often so sometimes we're
in a volume constraint situation
and of course you can get rid of weight
as well and
you'll see some applications today where
the weight constraint is really the
benefit of wireless power
or we're removing the weight constraint
now this is one where
i'm not sure i have the best uh
description of it but the two images you
see here are
are images of the the monolith from 2001
a space odyssey
so one way to think about this benefit
is you know imagine you have you know
future version of the iphone
here's here's an existing iphone it has
quite a few connectors and buttons and
things but you can imagine if you have
wireless power
and wireless data and if we sense you
know buttons
using some kind of capacitive rf sensing
technique
then you could imagine making something
like a phone that's just a completely
sealed
uh monolithic box that has
you know no ports or no no features
whatsoever and actually you'll see
several applications today where
what you might call boundary integrity
is is the key benefit
so it's not just for consumer
electronics but if you start thinking
about
biomedical applications that's a case
where you don't want extra ports being
put in your body
and we'll see some other examples of
that too
finally here's uh i've got emperor
palpatine from star wars helping us out
here for this one
i was talking to some nasa people about
the possibility of transferring power
wirelessly
between spacecraft and so there the
benefit is
non-contact energy transfer so you know
if you have these spacecraft that can
be sent off accidentally with small
amounts of force
then the fact that you don't have to use
force
to make and break connections is
potentially
a nice benefit so these things are all
similar and related but as we go i'll
point out when we're
taking advantage of different these
different benefits
now when i think about the space of
wirelessly powered systems
this is one of the ways i like to carve
it up so i have one axis which is
far field versus near field far field
literally means
further away probably in terms of rf
more than a wavelength
away and i also have some near field
work
and the far field systems tend to be
smaller amounts of power
longer range the near field systems are
larger amounts of power
shorter range and the other the other
axis
that i use is is you could call it wild
or planted
and that is you know is this power that
we deliberately transmitted with the
intention of collecting again later or
is this power that was already out there
for some reason
that we found and used and that's what
i'm calling wild
so each of these you know we've explored
several of these boxes and
these are the names of the systems that
uh
occupy uh each box and as we go i'll
talk about
the specifics so
one final uh sort of piece of
introduction is if you think about the
far field systems
the thing that has made these possible
is energy efficiency scaling
so if you look at this plot not very
carefully it looks like
kind of a moore's law plot that you've
probably seen many times the horizontal
axis has
you know time in decades but in this
case the vertical axis instead of being
number of transistors we can put on a
on a chip or in a certain area this is
actually in
number of instructions we can execute
per micro joule
so this is a plot of energy efficiency
and if you look
if you compare say eniac to a 2009
laptop
there's been a factor of about a
trillion improvement in energy
efficiency
and that is what is an enable enabling
these far-field
low-power applications that i'm going to
show you it's also kind of interesting
to note that there's
quite a bit of room for improvement if
you think of the brain as a as an
example
estimates of its energy efficiency put
it out here you know several
more orders of magnitude beyond where
our
digital computing is today this doesn't
mean that we don't get brains until 2040
which sometimes is what people
interpret this to be it just means that
our technology will not be as energy
efficient
as brains until then now this is a
related plot
the upper trace here i took uh
micro processors and microcontrollers
and plotted their energy efficiency in
the same units
instructions per micro joule
and then the bottom trace is if you
think about a particular workload that
we're going to execute using one of
these microcontrollers like
let's say make a sensor value make a
sensor measurement
encode the data maybe compute a crc and
then
something like that and then you ask
well you know what's the total
energy it takes to do that workload and
we assume we can transmit a certain
amount of power wirelessly
so you know the law allows us to
transmit a certain amount
that power falls off as one over r
squared
with distance so what that means is that
if i pick a particular workload and i
look
assume that i'm going to be able to
execute it on increasingly efficient
hardware
that means the range at which i'll be
able to execute that workload
is going up exponentially too but
because of the one over r squared
falloff
the slope of this range scaling curve
is is one half of the energy efficiency
curve
so this explains why you know 10 or 15
years ago people were able to start
making
far field uhf rfid tags
you know before that the energy
efficiency wasn't there
to do this but the more exciting thing
about it is it means that
the various things that we can do at
fairly short range today like
5 five to ten feet if this energy
efficiency scaling
trend continues we'll be able to do it
longer and longer range
and so i think that will take some of
the things i'm going to show you from
being kind of interesting novelties to
being something that is very practical
that you could really use in a variety
of applications
so the first system that i'm going to
describe is called
wisp which stands for wireless
identification and sensing platform
and this is basically a uhf rfid tag
that we created
from scratch so typically the way rfid
works is there's a reader
that emits well in this case 915
megahertz
rf carrier the tag
rectifies that rf energy and uses it to
power some digital logic
the way the tag communicates back to the
reader instead of having its own radio
radio transmitter oscillator all that
stuff
it uses a technique called backscatter
where it simply
changes the reflection coefficient of
this antenna so it has a little
transistor that it shorts
to short the two branches of the antenna
together or can choose not to short them
and that generates a reflection of the
reader's signal
so an analogy would be the reader's kind
of like a flashlight and the tag is sort
of like a mirror
and you know by moving the mirror you
can affect how much light gets reflected
back
so rather than having to have your own
ability to create light uh the tag just
does this backscatter
which is as you can imagine it's it's
very energy efficient because it's not
generating any
any rf signals it's just reflecting them
so the wisp
has a microcontroller which can actually
execute general purpose
programs we can also put sensors on it
and so it functions the same way as an
rfid tag in the sense that it's
wirelessly powered and it uses
very efficient backscatter communication
but other than that it's a lot more
capable
so what i'm going to show you in this
video is an early wisp
so this over here is a
rfid reader it's been dressed up to look
like a picture frame
and in my hand is a three axis
accelerometer wisp
so i'll play the movie here i'm working
the remote control with my other hand
which is
why i'm looking very strange there so
now as i
tilt this stack of boards back and forth
the accelerometer is
is seeing gravity showing up on the
three different channels the x
y and z channel of the accelerometer the
microcontroller is
reading the the values the analog
voltages that are coming out of that
accelerometer
it's encoding them computing a crc and
doing this back scatter communication
to encode the tilt for the reader which
is then drawing this this picture
so you can think of this as a kind of
like an input device and in fact this
accelerometer is the same thing it's in
the wii game controller
again the key kind of interesting thing
about this is that there's no battery
in that stack of boards and the other
thing i should emphasize sometimes
people look at this and they think it's
some kind of antenna polarization trick
or something like that
you know it's nothing like that that
that's a system that's being
you know powered by the rf and it's it's
digitally
communicating via backscatter so
in terms of what's inside that here's a
block diagram so
many of the blocks here are the same as
what you'd find in a conventional rfid
tag
the difference is the stuff on the right
so working in from the left
there's an antenna some impedance
matching
power harvesting circuitry that turns
the rf from the reader into usable
dc voltage there's a regulator voltage
regulator
oops i keep hitting that
and then these two components at the top
and bottom are also something you'd find
in a conventional rfid tag
demodulator extracts data from the
reader so the reader
is not always on it actually modulates
its amplitude in order to encode
downlink data data from the reader to
the tag and
then the modulator is simply a
transistor
that is used to short the the antenna as
i was describing before
so these blocks over here on the right
are the pieces that are unique to the
wisp so there's a microcontroller with
adc
and then external sensors and the state
machine instead of being implemented in
discrete
dedicated logic is is actually software
and that means we can program it
which has a lot of exciting uh
possibilities
so here's a view in a little more detail
of the blocks inside
the wisp so here's the rectifier that we
were using at that time
the demodulator and some power
management and i'll talk just a little
bit about each of those blocks
so this is actually a simulation of the
of a one-stage rectifier
and in this visualization color
corresponds to voltage and
dot velocity is current so it's kind of
nice that you can see them
both separately so over here would be
the
you know the input signal from the
antenna so you can see these dots are
just going
going back and forth so it's a ac or rf
signal
and then if you look at the the dots on
the diodes
say look at the bottom diode you can see
that the dots are only going up
so that's you know of course what the
diode does it only allows current to
pass in one direction
and if you kind of look at it you can
see
it's behaving sort of like a check valve
or something like that where
again the current only flows one
direction and so
you know driving it with an ac signal at
this point in this configuration
causes a dc output up here so if you
look at the dots up here
they're only going one direction because
of the rectification rectifying action
of the diodes
okay and then in this simulation we've
sort of ganged three of those
stages together and what that gives us
is voltage gain
so this point here where i'm putting the
mouse
is in this simulation is giving us 26
volts of dc
in this this point here this after the
second stage we're getting something
like 52 volts of dc
and after the third stage we're getting
78 volts so these component values
obviously aren't specific to rfid
but this gives you the idea and the
reason it's important to get some
voltage gain
is that even if we have sufficient power
to do the job that we want to do
if we don't have enough voltage the
electronics the microcontroller won't
turn on at all
so often range is constrained by voltage
and so that's that's why you're we're
interested in ways to to boost voltage
this shows the rectification efficiency
as a function of input power
so you can see it peaks here at about 32
or three percent something like this for
that particular
rectifier now this shows kind of the
behavior of the power management block
which is
sort of interesting so the red trace is
the harvested voltage so starting from
zero
this thing is waking up and then these
two
lines up here are two thresholds that we
have set
so there's a supervisor which is a piece
of hardware that detects a certain
voltage and then generates an interrupt
when that threshold is exceeded so the
microcontroller sleeps
until this upper threshold has been
exceeded
once there's enough voltage the
microcontroller wakes up
does its sensing does its communication
that causes it
to of course spend energy which
decreases the the available voltage
and it'll you know keep doing that until
it gets to this lower threshold
when it hits that lower threshold it'll
go to sleep and start charging back up
again
which is this upward trace now if
if the tag were further from the reader
there'd be less rf
energy coming in so this upward slope
would become shallower so it would take
longer to get back to the the charged up
state and then because the tag is you
know obeying the rfid protocol and so
forth
it's going to spend energy at basically
the same rate so the downward slopes
here are always going to be about the
same but what you'll see is this simple
mechanism of having these two thresholds
has the net effect of causing the tag to
delay in proportion to the you know
power available
and so on average the power expended by
the tag
ends up being exactly the same as the
power available so it's just a very
simple mechanism
that kind of has nice properties now
one of the things a lot of people are
working on now is more sophisticated
schemes that use
software because you know the size of
the job that you're executing
can affect the way you want to do this
duty cycling if i have
some job that takes longer to execute
then you know the amount of time i have
available here
then i may not be able to finish before
the uh
before the tag goes to sleep so various
ways of doing adaptive thresholds is
something that uh
you know many of my colleagues are
interested in
uh now okay so
we built the wisp uh the very first wisp
and
say the accelerometer that i showed you
i think that was actually 2006.
we we hardened it quite a bit further
than what you saw in that video
and then we made it available to
academic collaborators through a program
we called the wisp challenge so people
could propose applications we would send
them
uh send them some wisps and i'll show
you some of the applications
people have done so this one was kind of
a surprising one this was with some
neutrino physicists in italy
they're working on an underwater
neutrino telescope
that's going to be a kilometer on a side
under the mediterranean sea it consists
of 10 000
glass spheres which you can see here
that have photomultiplier tubes inside
them so what they're looking for is
when a neutrino comes through the water
it generates a flash of light and they
want to detect the sequence of flashes
and then figure out where the neutrinos
came from
now their thought is as long as they're
going to all the trouble to deplete
these ten thousand uh glass spheres
under the sea
they might as well try to do some
oceanography as well so they took
the wisp and they potted it on the
outside of the sphere
then they put a small rfid reader inside
the sphere
and found that they could successfully
make temper
temperature measurements that way so in
this case the benefit
to them was not that they wanted to
sense at long range
but they had this this boundary which is
the glass sphere
that is not not easy to breach so they
they can't just add additional uh
ports in this thing because you know
that'll cause
failures and or it's and it's expensive
to
to to create uh completely new uh
you know housings like this plus each
port that you have is further risk
so this is actually one of the examples
of of boundary integrity where
the the key benefit of wireless power in
this case is just getting through this
one centimeter of glass which is a you
know it's a high
there's a high pressure gradient across
it and and so you don't want to
have additional ports in that in that
glass
now here's a completely different
application
my student a lanson sample realized that
it's possible
to add buttons to rfid tags
essentially capacitive buttons to using
the same antenna
you know using the antenna for for the
rf purposes but also for the
the capacitive sensing so what you see
down here
is the signal applied to
to the antenna in the case that you're
not touching it
and then when you touch it you increase
the capacitance so the the
microcontroller is charging and
discharging in a certain pattern
where if you add the capacitance by
touching it it takes longer to charge
and discharge so this
gets stretched out but you can see that
you know these are the rf functions
they're still
unimpaired so the neat thing about this
is that you can imagine
you know taking an rfid chip that still
just has two wires
two ports but starting to add user
interface to it
so you know here's one button but you
can imagine doing a more sophisticated
version of this that would be a keypad
so for things like credit card
you know you could have a pin that you
enter and it would all be
implemented just using the basic rfid
capabilities
here's another this is a more recent
application so this is measuring eeg
using the wisp so artem here
created an eeg circuit that uh
he interfaced to the wisp so again this
is this is wirelessly
uh powered and red and you know there
are now input devices
you know gaming systems that uh that
work
you know that use eeg none of them are
wirelessly powered at the moment
now one of the challenges we discovered
uh when we did this
is that um you know the reader is
emitting this
large rf signal and it's and it's
modulating it the the very sensitive
voltage measurements that you're making
here
for the eeg tend to pick up the reader
so in this case right now
you multiplex between the sensing and
the communication
but i think this is an interesting
challenge for the future
you know the rfid protocols were
designed just for this tag
communication application uh they
weren't designed for sensing so it's
interesting to think about
you know can we redesign the entire
protocol
so that we can do sensing communication
power simultaneously
it's interesting to think about how
these different functions trade off with
one another
now here was a completely different
application of the wisp that took us by
surprise
when we built the wisp we thought it was
all about sensing
but my colleague kevin foo
is very interested in security and
cryptography and
it turns out there's a there's a whole
community of people working on rfid
cryptography for things like payment
transactions and things like that and in
the past there had you know before the
wisp there had never been a way
to actually implement applications and
write code that would run on an rfid tag
because they were just black boxes
so working with kevin we we implemented
the rc5 encryption algorithm on the wisp
and
so that's interesting first because we
were able to just write software to do
something
on a tag also the conventional wisdom
had been that
because rfid tags are so power
constrained you need special
low power cryptography but most of those
low power cryptographic schemes were
broken
and here we just used a conventional you
know full strength
uh crypto crypto system um and i think
you know if you look at the energy
efficiency scaling that i showed at the
beginning
that's part of the reason why you know
this makes more and more sense as time
goes on and people have gone on to
implement
many other crypto systems uh using the
wisp in fact here here's another example
so intel uh commercialized the wisp
design
for an application in brazil called
cineav
which is basically a tolling system a
kind of augmented tolling system so in
many places
you have these tags that you put in your
windshield that are
essentially rfid tags that are used that
are used to pay tolls
well in brazil they want to use that
sort of system for many other things as
well
they want to use it for buying gas so
you buy drive into the gas station and
you're just billed for the gas that you
use
or you go into the parking lot and the
payment happens that way
so to make that happen they wanted a lot
more security than the conventional rfid
uh offered so there's their standard
calls
for using the aes the advanced
encryption standard
and so for us we were able to just write
some software run it on the tag
and then we had an aes compliance system
the other people working on this the
other competitors
had to design digital logic and you know
took a long time so
our team was able to get to market a lot
faster
because of this software approach
so another sort of application
that my student eve zao has been working
on recently
is doing ultrasonic localization
uh implemented on the wisps so
localization is a problem that
people in rfid have been interested in
for a long time because
you know given rf propagation it's
difficult to localize
rfid tags it's difficult to find out
where exactly the tag is because
you know because of the you know
strange ways that that rf propagation
changes when someone comes into the room
or a door opens or closes things like
that it's hard to use the rf signals
themselves to precisely localize
something
so here the idea is to combine
ultrasonic localization with
with rf so the idea is that the rfid
reader
now will emit some ultrasound the tags
have
ultrasound detectors the rf signal tells
all the tags to start their timers
and the rf propagation is practically
instantaneous
but it takes a long time for the for the
ultrasound to get there
because you know rf propagates at one
nanosecond per foot whereas
acoustic signals propagate at one
millisecond
per foot um so each tag sits there
waiting for the ultrasound pulse to come
in
measures when the when the ultrasound
arrives and then transmits that data
back to the reader
using backscatter and then the reader
can
localize the tags that way so that
mechanism of dual rf ultrasound had been
proposed before for example by the
by the crickets and mit project but the
the nice thing here is that
uh this is you know battery free and uh
also integrates with rfid infrastructure
so that if you have some kind of
tracking system and readers
you could potentially use this fairly
easily
okay now here's a very new project this
is going to be
coming out at the yuba comp conference
in september
so the board that you see on the right
we call the nfc wisp
so this is nfc's near field
communication
and this is a standard that's being
built into many phones now
so you know android some android phones
have this for example so essentially the
phone is an nfc reader so that
this is 13 megahertz or you know hf
rather than
uhf but so this board here
can receive power from the phone and
transmit data bi-directionally oops so
what we've done over here
is we've integrated the nfc wisp with an
e-ink display
so now you can take your phone put it up
to this display thing
shake the phone the phone
powers the powers the nfc wisp with
display
sends in this case an image of the
screen
so it captures a screenshot which gets
written onto the ink display and because
the e-ink is by stable
once you've once you've set each pixel
black or white they stay without any
further power
so the the by stable display is kind of
a nice match to wireless power when you
may or may not have power available
when you have the power you set the
display then the power goes away and the
display changes
so there are probably many other
applications for things like this you
can imagine having something on your
door
which is a kind of yank sign that you
could interact with with your phone
maybe it would also have a far-field uhf
rfid interface so you could you know set
an appointment or a note on the
right on this display on the door and
then it would also propagate to the rest
of the building and calendar systems and
things like that
so i think this is this is going to be
an interesting
set of things to do and i also wanted to
highlight this because this is the first
example i've showed so far of a display
that is
that is wirelessly powered now all the
wisps that i showed you so far the most
recent one was the
we called it the wisp 4.0 a little
advertisement we're coming out with the
wisp
5.0 which will have longer range and
more
memory and so forth and we're going to
do a similar project
a similar program to the wisp challenge
in fact my colleague david weatherall
and i just got a
million dollar nsf grant through the
let's see what's it called computing
research infrastructure program to
make these and readers available to the
research community
so that's something that hopefully by
the end of the summer we'll have
available okay so now
oops i'm going to talk about another
recent
project where we wanted to
go to much higher data rates for uh for
a wirelessly powered sensor system
so what i showed you uh with with
that first wisp video was an
accelerometer that was being measured
maybe 20
20 or 30 times a second what i'm going
to show you here is a way to do audio
which is much higher data rate sensing
but all using far field
you know battery free sensing and so for
inspiration here we
we're going back to something called the
great seal bug which probably some of
you know the story of
this uh this device was invented
probably by the uh
the inventor leon theremin who was
kidnapped from the united states taken
back to russia forced to work on bugs
seems like this is the bug or one of the
bugs that he came up with so
some soviet boy scout equivalents gave
this
great seal of the united states to the
american ambassador
they measured it didn't seem to be
emitting any rf signals
didn't have any batteries so they
thought it was okay so he hung it in his
office for
seven years and it turned out that it
was a bug the whole time
and the way that it worked was actually
a version of backscatter
so the audio in the room would cause
this diaphragm to vibrate
some kind of metallized membrane
and that would change the reflection
coefficient of this antenna
so a truck would be parked outside the
antenna the the embassy broadcasting
microwave
you know rf uh in um and based on the
sound in the room
the the amount of of rf reflected would
change
so the audio in the room was essentially
modulating
uh the the back scattered rf
so that's basically what led to
backscatter communication as as
as i was showing you earlier
so in the conventional wisp we have a
transistor
that's used to short the two branches of
the antenna together so we're just doing
binary you know two levels of
backscatter
but what what we're proposing here or
what we've done here is to take a
conventional wisp
then add a microphone and and an analog
switch in series with the mic so now we
can talk to the wisp
in the conventional way it has a unique
id we can send it
a command to enable the the microphone
which case it closes the switch and now
the microphone is going to be directly
connected to the antenna
and so it's going to go into an analog
backscatter mode where it's actually
backscattering audio
in the same way that this great seal bug
did so what you see in the blue up here
this this part is the digital
communication
digital traffic between the tag and
reader and then
when it goes into analog backscatter
mode you see this trace here so this is
actually audio
that is being backscattered and now i'm
going to play you two samples
the first was uh from a distance of
0.7 meters so that the microphone
uh and the wisp is is here the reader is
is you know less than a meter away oops
sorry okay here comes the audio now
here's something we hope you'll really
like
sorry that was too loud anybody
recognize that
rocky and bullwinkle now here it is from
seven meters away
oops
so a lot more noise and sounds like an
am radio because
it is you know am modulation
but i think that you know the thing
that's exciting about this is now we
have a microphone that has no batteries
that we can read
from you know fair distance away
and so that's a much more demanding
sensing challenge than than what i
showed you earlier with the 20 uh
samples per second
uh sensing
and there's obviously a lot of room for
improvement with that
but but i think it's an exciting result
okay so everything i've showed you so
far
was example of wisp and in all those
systems we were deliberately
transmitting
the rf power so we had a reader whose
purpose was to put out the rf power we
were going to use
but it turns out that using similar
rectification techniques we can capture
power
from ambient sources like tv or cell
phones
so we call this project wireless ambient
radio power
and the image you see on the left is
that this is a tv tower in seattle
uh which puts out a megawatt uh
rf energy and then this is a commercial
wideband tv antenna uhf
is the band that we're using and
we're using essentially the same
rectifier that that that was used in the
wisp
and in this example we're just powering
a commercial off the shelf kitchen
thermometer
so that was a first just proof of
concept the map that you see on the
right
shows the location of that one megawatt
tower
and the inner circle is the range at
which you'd expect to be able to
get about a hundred micro watts and then
if this further circle
you'd expect to be able to get 25
microwatts
and the image you see up here is a newer
harvester
using just uh you know a dipole antenna
so rather than this
large wideband antenna this antenna is
tuned to one particular frequency
i think it's like 739 megahertz
something like that
but it's and it's obviously a lot
smaller than the
the broadband antenna
so more recently we've been able to
harvest from cell phone towers so
the map over here on the right is the
university of washington campus so
there's a large
fountain here and on top of this
building
there's a cell phone tower you know
array of antennas
at these green locations where we were
able to
harvest power from from those base
cell phone base stations do a sensor
measurement and transmit
data a short distance using like a
zigbee like radio
and then at these two locations the red
locations it didn't work
which my theory is it's maybe some sort
of a
multi-path you know bounce off this
water but we haven't investigated that
yet
so in this case you know the range is is
a lot less than with tv here we're
looking at 200 meters something like
that
but you know sometimes people ask well
is tv going to go away
broadcast tv maybe it will i don't think
cell phone
signals are ever going to go away
but i think the density will increase
and increase so
this is maybe not quite enough power to
do everything that you want well clearly
it's not quite enough to do everything
that you want now but
if cells cells get smaller and smaller
and more and more numerous
this may become increasingly practical
as a way to power
electronics now the way that we did uh
the way we were able to to operate using
the cell phone power
actually required a new type of
harvester so this is our old harvester i
showed you a simulation of something
like this
a few minutes ago you can see it's just
a bunch of diodes
schottky diodes in this case
what we found is that when the signals
get very very small
corresponding to be being very far away
from the reader
you do better having just a single stage
of rectification
followed by a dc to dc converter to get
the voltage gain
and so that allowed us this new design
allowed us to go from
negative 9 dbm sensitivity or
corresponding to 125 microwatts
as the minimum that you would need to
operate
that allowed us to move to negative 18
dbm sensitivity which corresponds to
something like 15 micro watts
or in terms of range that's you know 3x
range improvement so again just to
emphasize the
the various constraints you know
power in some sense is not really a
constraint because the tag
can sleep for as long as it wants in
principle to accumulate
enough energy to do the thing it needs
to do so if you're willing to adjust
duty cycle as much as you want
you can always in principle match your
power uh
required to power available on the other
hand voltage is
more of a hard constraint if you don't
have enough voltage
the thing won't turn on at all and no
matter how long you're willing to wait
the thing won't operate
so it's important to be able to to get
the voltage gain that you need
on the other hand one of the nice things
about the voltage constraint is that
you know voltage is not a conserved
quantity so you know this box is
actually
generating more voltage than uh then
you're providing to it
so that's that's one of the kind of
engineering uh
opportunities is is to find ways to to
get voltage gain
when you need it now this plot here in
the middle
shows that the horizontal axis is is
basically range
in meters so this is 10 kilometers 20
kilometers
the blue is the old harvester design and
the green is the new harvester design
so you can see that the old design
basically stops working all together at
about 10 kilometers whereas this new
design with the dc-dc converter will
work well beyond
20 kilometers the other thing is that
short range
the the old design is actually better
and so one of the things we're working
on now is trying to come up with a
design that will win
both at high power relatively high power
and low power
okay so the next uh project i'm going to
show you is a collaboration with my
colleague sean golakota at university of
washington
and our students now one of the ways i
like to think about this
is you know i described the wisp project
which
used backscatter communication and we
talked about warp which is ambient rf
uh power so powering things off ambi rf
signals
this is sort of putting those two things
together so we have these these devices
these abc
devices that are powered by the signals
from the tv tower
then they communicate with each other by
back scattering
the signals from the tv tower so just
just as the wisp did to talk to the
reader
this tag over here has a transistor it
can use to short
the two branches of this antenna
together and it turns out that when it
does that
this nearby tag can actually detect a
change
in the incoming signal which you know
i've
plotted here now this doesn't work at
long
very long range these two tags have to
be quite near each other
like less than an antenna length away
from one another but
but it's really kind of exciting that
that you can do this because
what it means is you you have these tags
that have no
particular infrastructure other than
some ambient rf
these things can be powered perpetually
continuously and they can communicate
with each other
even though you didn't have to deploy
any infrastructure so from kind of a
user's point of view it's
it's almost like being able to have an
rfid
system but with no rfid reader
the only reader essentially is the tv
tower
now you would have to of course one big
difference is now all the communication
has to be multi-hop and you'd probably
need some sort of a gateway to collect
messages from the other
units and and then send them uh
somewhere else but
it's it's it's an exciting new
capability
now we've done a couple of sort of
demonstration applications here
uh we built these capacitive buttons
onto this one
and there are a couple of leds on here
so the first application we
uh implemented was kind of a payment
type
application so let's say each one of
these is a card with maybe some stored
value and i want to transfer some of
that value from one card to another
i swipe the finger across it back
scatters a message to the other one
if it's received correctly and this one
we just have it checking as crc
if it's received correctly it flashes
one of its other leds
now of course that led is very small and
it's only on for a very short period of
time because we don't have a lot of
energy but
it is something you can see and the
other thing is of course the update rate
is low so
the led can flash once every five six
seconds something like that
um so we've we've uh you know
done this done this outdoors on the
balcony
at our lab where you have a decent view
of the tv tower and
we've experimented with the
communication
performance so the horizontal axis in
this plot here is distance between the
the units so you can see it ranges from
you know half a foot up to about 3 feet
this vertical axis is the bit error rate
and then the three colored plots are
different data rates so the red is 100
bits per second
the green is one kilobit per second and
the blue is 10 kilobits per second
so you can see that you know if we're
willing to go slowly as 100 bits per
second we can get a couple of feet away
and have you know a very very low uh er
error rate
if we're going to go start going faster
like 10 kilobits per second we're going
to have a higher error rate
unless we're very very close like half a
foot
so another application we've explored is
imagine something like books which are
all kind of uniform you know books in a
library let's say
each could have a tag like this and the
tags can talk to each other
so in principle
a system like this could figure out
where every book is each book would
tell its neighbor where it is if one is
off that could be detected
or you could just you know pass the
messages
and figure out where everything is
so it's not clear exactly where this is
going but uh it's it's a really
exciting and different way of doing
things because
you know we have these units that
potentially can last forever
can be completely built into something
else
and really don't need a lot of
infrastructure to to be able to function
so if you step back and think about all
of these uh things that i've showed you
so far
what i think is exciting about it is
that we've demonstrated that we can do
rf powered battery free versions of
many of the components of various kinds
of ubiquitous
computing systems that you might be
interested in so i've showed you
environmental sensing for example in the
temperature sensing in the nemo project
several different input devices so we
did accelerometer
touch sensing eeg and microphones
i showed you a couple of cryptography
examples
i showed you one location system the
ultrasound wisp
one display although that was hf so it's
a little bit different
and then just now with the abc system i
showed you
peer-to-peer communication which you
could think of as kind of readerless
rfid
but you know in aggregate if you step
back and look at all
these things we have many of the pieces
of
kind of ubiquitous or even mobile
computing systems that are now
starting to be possible to be rf powered
with no batteries so i think it's going
to be exciting to start putting these
capabilities together
into complete working systems
so that basically concludes the far
field
portion of the talk and now i'm going to
tell you
about uh the near field high power
uh system let me just do a time check so
are we going till 5 30 5 30. okay
technically to late in the morning but
you know
okay we'll be here all night um
okay so let's do go off though the next
uh
system i'm gonna describe is called
wireless resonant energy link
uh which we pronounce whirl apologies
for the uh
pronunciation there so this
this was the the first uh world system
that we got working this is
lansin and um well you'll see as he puts
down this uh
60 watt light bulb you'll see it being
lit up from about three feet away
from the transmit coil and back there
and that's about 75 percent efficiency
coil to coil so now i'll explain a
little bit about how that works
so the coils on the transmit side
are represented here so it's several
turns of copper
and that has some inductance and some
capacitance
it has a resonant frequency determined
by these two values the received side
also is a
tuned circuit tuned to the same
frequency
and as it happens we inductively couple
into those which isn't too
important for our purposes but if you
work out the whole
transfer function for the system you get
this kind of messy expression
and in a minute i'm going to show you a
plot of that that is going to make it
much more intuitive
a key point is we can figure out how
this thing behaves
and now i'm going to show you a
mechanical analog
for this that will give you some
intuition onto how it works
so this is a simulation of the
mass and spring system you see up here
so the transmit
coil is analogous to a single mass and a
spring
which has a certain natural frequency
determined by the mass
and the spring constant just the way the
lc circuit is
determined by the the l and c values
the received side is also a another mass
in spring
and then the magnetic field that couples
those things together that we're
actually using to transfer the power
is like this spring here now it turns
out when you have a system like this
with
two coupled resonators
instead of having one resonant frequency
there are actually two resonant
frequencies or two normal modes
so this plot what you're seeing
simulated here is the in phase mode
where the two masses are moving together
and then now i'm switching it to the
anti-phase mode where they're always
opposite
and those two modes are both you know
resonant frequencies at which the system
absorbs energy very efficiently
and the frequencies of those two modes
are different
from one another and it turns out that
the tighter i make the spring in the
center
the greater the splitting which means
the greater the difference in frequency
between the in-phase mode and the
anti-phase mode
and so now i'm going to show you a plot
of that transfer function
this is it right here so
the vertical axis is efficiency
this left axis here is distance between
the transmit coil and receive coil
and then this axis over here is
frequency so
at very short distances we have a large
degree of splitting so
when the transmitter and receiver are
close to each other that corresponds to
a very tight
spring in the in the mechanical analog
and now if you pick a distance like
let's say 10 centimeters and trace
across here
you can see we're going to hit one peak
first which is the
the in phase mode and then we're going
to hit another peak over here
which is the anti-phase mode
so this surface is sort of the key to
how this wireless power system works
so the key observation is that if we had
a control system that could pick the
frequency
as the distance changed then we could
stay on top of this ridge
so even as a transmitter and receiver
move back and forth from one another
we're going to adjust the frequency to
stay on top of that ridge
and what that means is that we're going
to get relatively constant efficiency
so if i were viewing this v-shaped
plateau from the side
it looks fairly flat on top so
the key idea here is that as the
transmitter receive
move with respect to one another either
in distance or
orientation turns out to to work as well
we're going to adjust the system
properties to keep the efficiency
basically constant
and the thing that surprised me about
this at first is that
you know when i had thought about
wireless power systems uh in the past i
always just
kind of assume that the further away the
receiver is the less power you get
but what this shows is that in this
regime inside this this red box
if this if the control system is working
correctly then we actually get constant
efficiency
uh even as the the geometry changes
and so now i'm going to show you a movie
the first section of the movie we don't
have auto tuning on and in the
then in the next section you'll see auto
tuning enabled
so what you notice is the light is on at
some particular distance this is with no
auto tuning
when it's either too far or too close
from the transmitter the light is off
so back in terms of that plot we were
going right up the middle and over
over the top now we're turning on auto
tuning so now the transmitter is
changing its frequency in response to
what's going on
and you can see that the light basically
stays on
essentially all the time even as we
change the orientation
and so forth and here's one other kind
of neat trick this is
range extension so now the receiver's
out of range we put this other coil in
the middle and the power actually
multi-hops across
so in terms of mechanical analog that
would now we have three masses
coupled by spring so they get more and
more complicated
well it you know it keeps going uh quite
a ways we've done
five or six hops you can also make it
turn the corner which is kind of
interesting
and when you have multiple of these
together the dynamics can get very
complicated so sometimes something
strange will happen where you'll move
one coil a little bit and
one of the other lights will go on and
then move it back and a different one
will go off so
it gets it gets quite complicated when
you use it doesn't it
so so it doesn't become chaotic fairly
quickly
it's not chaotic i mean it's a it's a
system of you know n-coupled
resonators and you can figure out the
eigenfunctions and
you know figure out what happens
pendulums become chaotic very quickly
and they're
coupled oscillators well yeah
maybe there's some regime where this you
could make this chaotic
or okay yeah although pendulums are
non-linear once you get beyond a certain
height
i'm not sure if that's important to the
chaos
okay now
one question that comes up a lot of
course is uh you know is this safe
and you know that's that's really a key
question is
at what power level you know is this
safe and legal
so we've been working with the itis
foundation in switzerland who
are experts in modeling the interaction
of
rf signals with the human body and
they have they call the virtual family
which is basically they took
cat scans of uh you know four four
people
uh uh different sizes and shapes
and then they electrically they
annotated the electrical properties of
all the organs in the body
then they can take those models stick
them into their simulator into an
em simulator and calculate exactly how
much heating
would occur for different applied
fields so you know here we did some
simulations with the transmit coils
in different configurations and from
this
you know from the initial uh work it
looks like something like 50 watts
is uh is safe um
now obviously for every specific
situation you you have to look at you
know every specific application you'd
have to look at it more carefully and
see
if if you satisfy the various
regulations
but you know the reason you go to such
high power levels is because the
transmitter is
mostly generating a magnetic field which
basically doesn't interact
with your body when you have an electric
field
the water molecules in your body are
electrically polar and they orient to
the electric field that's of course how
a microwave oven heats up
food or water so to the extent you can
have just a magnetic field you're
basically able to
transfer power without interacting with
the body of course the changing magnetic
field generates a secondary
electric field like eddy currents and so
forth and those are the things that
ultimately limit
the power level that you can go to
so now i'll tell you about some of the
applications of this that we've been
exploring
the board that you see on the right is
just a
kind of fun receiver board so
i showed you in the initial plot that
there was both a coil and a loop
what you see here is the loop the other
side of the board has a coil
meaning several turns so this board
receives
wireless power and it has a usb
connector here that's actually the power
out
so you can take this board take any usb
device
plug it into this thing and um
and and power it so
let's see now here's another just sort
of fun application where we have this
message fan
it's a little hard to see in the video
but basically this motor spinning around
and there are leds along the the fan
blades
um and so we're we're turning them on
so of course inside that white box
there's no battery it's all
being powered by the uh the wireless
power from the
transmit coil there so
that one is just sort of fun we're
collaborating with
rob wood at harvard to try to wirelessly
power their
robo bees so that group is
creating basically robotic bees using a
new kind of
mesoscale fabrication techniques but if
you look in their
videos there are always at least so far
fine
wires coming in that are providing the
power to to operate the b
so we're trying to uh wirelessly power
this so at first it'll just be a simple
system where we have
a series of transmit coils the b always
flies up
and it'll just fly parallel to those now
obviously long term you need
you need some sort of a far field system
if you want the b to be able to go long
distances but
our next step is just to show that this
can be done using the near field
approach
now another area where we're applying
this is
we have a center that is joint between
the university of washington
mit san diego state university and
there's some other partners as well
but this is an nsf engineering research
center
for sensory motor neural engineering and
i'm the thrust leader for communications
interface so what we're trying to do
here is wirelessly power
certain type of brain implant called uh
electrochordatography
so there are several different
ways of making brain measurements
earlier i showed you
eeg electroencephalography where you're
measuring from outside the skull
so you don't get very good signals that
way because you know the neural activity
propagates through the skull and you
know
it gets kind of mixed up
ecog is a system where you apply
electrodes to the surface of the brain
and that gives you of course much better
signal than you can get through the
skull
but it's actually less invasive than
individual neural spike measurement
systems
so there are arrays of essentially
needles that get inserted
into the brain and those give the best
signals they can measure the activity of
individual neurons
but obviously it's more invasive to
actually stick a needle into the brain
so ecog is something that's uh there's
quite a bit of expertise at university
of washington and
right now it's mostly used for patients
who have you know tremors and
parkinson's and things like that
or you know seizures uh various types
so today it's used on a fairly short
term basis
uh for diagnosis so a patient will come
into the hospital they'll put in an
e-cog system leave it there for a week
or two
they'll find out where the seizures are
occurring and you know make a treatment
plan based on that
but the thought is that if you could
completely implant an e-cog system
then potentially you could put these in
and leave them there basically
permanently
which could be used for these
therapeutic purposes
but also potentially for brain control
you know brain control interfaces and
things like that
so in this application we're very size
constrained because the goal is to put
the whole thing inside the skull
so we have to do a chip for this so
working with my colleague brian otis
we're designing an e-cog
chip that can be
can be wirelessly powered using our hf
uh wireless power system
now this is the most exciting
application actually of of our wireless
power
on the right is a picture of my
collaborator
dr pramad bondi he's a heart surgeon at
yale school of medicine
and on the left you see a heart pump
called the left ventricular assist
device so this is an alternative to
a total artificial heart where instead
of taking out the old diseased heart
you put in a pump in parallel with the
heart
so the old heart is still there doing
what it can but now you have this
mechanical assist
um now when you put a pump in parallel
with the heart
that consumes a lot of energy it takes
something like
you know between 5 watts and 30 watts to
power that pump so
there's really no possibility of battery
powering this the way you can
battery power a pacemaker defibrillator
so today there's actually a cord that
protrudes from the abdomen
that brings the power and control
signals into this pump
and as you can imagine that gets
infected and that
seems like is really limiting uh how
much
lvads can be used so there are something
like 500 000 cases of
heart failure there are about 2 000
lvads in planet a year also only about 2
000 transplants a year
so there's potentially a lot of
opportunity if you could solve the
infection problem
to have lvads become a much more widely
used therapy
so that's what we're trying to do is
eliminate the
transcutaneous driveline so in this
here's
one visualization over here on the right
of of how this could work
so the patient would have a receive coil
and plant it under the skin
the controller for the motor and the
motor as well as the rf rectification
circuitry would all be implanted
then outside there would be a transmit
coil which could be worn in a vest
along with some batteries and then
kind of what we'd really like to do
longer term is
have a transmit coil that could go in
certain key pieces of furniture such as
a bed
and then maybe the vest wouldn't be
needed while you're sleeping
obviously to go out and so forth you'd
still need the vest
and in this application we think it's
going to be necessary to have an
implanted battery as well that would
provide maybe
you know half an hour of operation so
that the patient could shower
you know change the vest etc
so this shows kind of many of the pieces
that are in the system that we've
built for for the heart
application i think i won't talk through
all the details of this one
okay in this video i'm going to show you
this is my student ben waters with a
wearable portable transmitter so this
would be analogous to the vest that i
just showed you so that's the transmit
coil
sometimes he's not a suicide bomber
now he's going to pull out a receive
coil
and you can see it coming on
people usually say iron man when they
see this thing
um you can see it's you know
it's approximately you know it's the
distance that you would need
for some reason he didn't want to have
that coil implanted inside him so we did
the demo with that outside
um oops
whoa okay so um
we did we did implant this in a couple
of pigs which i won't
leave up for very long but uh so we've
done some initial
you know experiments which show that the
full system does work
and that was successful
so that basically concludes the
description of of wirelessly powered
systems that we've worked on
so you know we talked about first
far-field systems
so there's wisp which is a system in
which we're transmitting power
deliberately
then we talked about warp which is
another far-field system but
there it's using ambient rf and we
talked about
ambient backscatter communication where
we sort of combine those two ideas
and have tags that can communicate with
each other using just ambient rf signals
and then i showed you the near field
systems so world is
is our name for the the high power
wireless system and freed is what we
call the
application to heart heart pumps um
so overall you know when i step back and
think of you know what are the
implications of all of this
i think one exciting possibility is that
we may be able to have
you know zero power uh communication of
certain types so
for example your phone may be completely
dead
but it may be possible to still send an
sms using
power that you've you've harvested from
from ambient rf
and i also showed you the analog
backscatter where we were actually
collecting audio
using using ambient rf as the power so
maybe
you know it may be possible to even
transmit some voice
this way so overall i think it's
increasingly
feasible to run mobile ubiquitous
computing systems using ambient rf power
and as time goes on given the energy
scaling that i showed you earlier
i think these things are going to come
become more and more practical more and
more compelling
i'm going to put up a little
advertisement for a book that i have
edited
as a collection of papers on many of
these these topics both
by my group and by other collaborators
also there's a new journal from
cambridge university press coming out on
wireless power transfer so
i encourage you to submit to that if
you're interested
now i have some robotics uh work that i
also do but i think
given that we're almost out of time i
don't know
should i talk about a little bit of that
or we'll go until we turn off the camera
then we'll do cool stuff
okay then toss out the gold bars sounds
sounds good i better be here in person
for the gold bars
all right so um
robotics is one of the application areas
that that i'm very interested in
uh for for sensor systems so far what
i've been talking about is
this problem of powering sensors which
is a very important problem
but here i'm going to look at some new
sensors designed for
specific applications of of robotics
now to back up the video i'm showing you
here is
what i worked on for my phd thesis so
there's an array of electric field
measurements
and it's measuring my my hand uh the way
my hands interact with the electric
field and we're inferring
what the hand position and orientation
for both hands is from that
that led to kind of a surprising
technology transfer where
honda ended up creating a car seat
sensor using this
this sensing mechanism to disable
passenger side airbag firing so now
every honda that's been made since about
2001 has uh has our sensor in it
and if your head is near the airbag the
side airbag
it's disabled using that that sensing
technique
but in robotics i've taken it a couple
of different directions
so in this application
i'm going to show you a robot that is
sensing
power sensing the 60 hertz electric
field emissions from the outlet so you
can think of this as a robot that's kind
of finding its own
food of course this food is electricity
so every outlet has a 60
hertz emission that it that it generates
so we took the ground plug
of the robot instrumented it with the
sensor
and as it was scanning back and forth
there it was looking for the peaks
in in the 60 hertz uh and then aligning
to
to to plug in
now in this example this is really
taking the exact same sensing technique
that i showed you for the uh
for the hand sensing but now we're
building the sensors into the robot hand
instead of going the other way so this
is inspired by
several species of fish since their
environments this way they generate an
electric field and look at how things
change
and what you're going to see in this
video the first part we're measuring
between the palm
there's a transmitter in the palm and
receiver in the fingertips
and so each of the fingertips has this
sensor and so by balancing those sensor
values
you can align the hand with the the
object
and then once it's aligned it switches
into another mode where it's using
a transmitter kind of in the back of the
finger that's sensing on a shorter range
to align with
the the apple and finally the other
thing you'll see in this video is that
we can tell whether i'm touching the
object or not because when i touch it i
ground it
and so the center can distinguish that
and you'll hear some beeps
that indicate whether the person is
touching the object or not
this is using the long range sensors and
once the signals get stable it switches
into the
rounded finger sensing
that beeping is it detecting whether
you're touching it so wait's first
that beep was it detecting him touching
it and it releases once he's touched it
um okay now
that uh that sensing mechanism turned
out to be pretty nice
and i'll show you another really fun
application of it in a minute
but one problem that we had with that or
one shortcoming was that
it depends on the electrical properties
of the material and so
it works for many materials but things
that are like a
thin plastic case uh you know it doesn't
work for so we wanted to come up with
another
pre-touch sensing mechanism that
would respond to a different set of
materials so i call this
seashell effect pre-touch and here the
idea is
when you take a seashell and put it up
to your ear you hear the sound of the
sea
of course that's not really the sea what
it is is that the cavity has
properties it filters the ambient sound
in the room and as you get it closer and
further from your head
the properties of that filter change so
we're going to do the same thing we take
a pipe
instead of a c shell put a microphone in
it and as that pipe approaches an object
the the way the pipe filters the sound
in the room
change so we have a reference microphone
that's not in the pipe we have another
microphone in the pipe
and then we're going to build that whole
thing into a robot finger
so here's our pr2 robot these are the
the pipes that i was describing with the
microphones
and this shows uh as a function of
distance
the the the frequency um that
that we observe so you can see you know
with standard deviation everything so
you can very reliably use this as a
as a sensor to detect whether you're
close to an object or not
and so we've used that for various
applications
this first section of the video you're
going to see a pressure sensor very
compliant object the pressure sensor
is not able to detect the the paper
because it has some minimum force that
it can sense
now here we're using the pre-touch
sensor which can detect the paper
you know without touching it so you can
think of it as sort of a force sensor
that has no lower limit on
on what it can detect
and then here's a more complicated
application where we
we start with a point cloud connected
collected by the connect that's these
little
red dots here then we're going to use
the pre-touch sensor to augment the
point cloud
there we go
so we infer some other points there
unfortunately i'm not going to have time
to explain this really properly but
we guess about the existence of some
other points then we plant a grasp
and if the points we want to use for
grasping are uncertain
meaning we didn't actually observe them
we just guessed that there was something
there
then we're going to use the pre-touch to
fill in those points and
so we just filled in some points that
were detected with the pre-touch sensor
then we replant the grasp using those
new points
and uh if the process converges
then you know eventually we get to a
point where the the points we want to
grasp
have we're sure have something there and
we go ahead and do the grasp
so eventually the idea is to combine the
grasping procedure with this pre-touch
sensing
so that it just happens as all all part
of one process
right so finally i'm going to show you a
video where we were able to
kind of demonstrate this in a kind of
high visibility
fun setting so this is similar to what i
showed you
with the apple
that's craig barrett governor
schwarzenegger
and chancellor merkel of germany
they're shaking hands with the robot
here
he says it's his drinking hand so he's
glad he's not squeezing any harder
and now what i learned in this was that
chancellor merkel has a
phd in physics and she's actually about
to do an experiment
unplanned experiments
that right now
so that beeping is the same thing you
heard before it's detecting whether
you're touching the object
so when he touches it the beef happens
it releases
so this is the ribbon to launch c-bet
and now watch chancellor merkel's little
experiment she
she touches that ball and you heard the
beeping that was it detecting the fact
that she touched it
but fortunately
fortunately it was no longer programmed
to release at that point so if it had
done the same thing it was
doing with the orange it would have let
go in front of thousands of people the
ribbon would have dropped and
it would have been very embarrassing but
uh so that was one where the demo gods
smiled on us so if you imagine putting
all this together you know i showed you
various
wirelessly powered sensors uh implanted
sensors
you can imagine having wisp like brain
sensors that are used to pick up
motor commands from you know a paralyzed
person
the kinds of pre-touch sensors i just
showed you in a
in a prosthetic arm maybe that arm is
wirelessly recharged
so i think it's exciting to imagine what
you could do putting all of this
together
and with our neural engineering center
we're actually trying to do many of
these things
so that's it thank you very much for
your attention
you